herzlich willkommen bei zdf heute live
schön dass ihr dabei seid mein name ist
barbara hahlweg ich bin heute das erste
mal an dieser stelle dabei bitte also
schon mal um nachsicht wenn
möglicherweise nicht alles so rund läuft
wie es sein sollte was schon geimpft das
ist eine frage die einen derzeit
häufiger auf den lippen brennt und
mitunter auch neid gefühle auslöst erst
recht jetzt wo heute mittag der
bundestag die erleichterungen für
geimpfte verabschiedet hat heißt wer
vollständig gegen korona geimpft oder
davon genesen ist muss künftig keine
ausgangs beschränkungen beachten
er darf mehr menschen treffen als nicht
geimpfte braucht keine tests mehr für
friseur oder shoppen ist das klug ist
das gerecht oder schürt das night und
spaltet das die ohnehin schon
aufgewühlte gesellschaft darüber wollen
wir sprechen auch darüber was gegen
neidgefühle hilft und zwar mit dem
psychologen und neid experten jens lange
als hamburg und mit der vorsitzenden des
ethikrats alina biggs herzlich
willkommen schön dass sie dabei sind und
wir freuen uns natürlich über eure
fragen und anregungen wie gewohnt in der
kommentarspalte bei youtube oder
facebook oder auch per mail an uns und
bevor wir zu den fragen kommen blicken
wir jetzt aber erstmal nach mainz dort
haben wir die menschen gefragt wie sie
es finden dass geimpfte künftig mehr
dürfen als nicht kämpfte ein bisschen
neid ist der glaube ich doch schon im
spiel aber jetzt gerade im hinblick auf
die älteren bin ich für die eher
glücklich dass wir jetzt die
möglichkeiten haben tatsächlich
ungestört und auch ohne angst wieder
rauszugehen und auch leben auch am
sozialen leben wieder wirklich
teilnehmen zu können
also ich finde es grundsätzlich gut am
anfang
hatte ich da auch eine zweigeteilte
meinungen drüber wenn es darum geht dass
die gesellschaft wie gespalten wird
aber letztendlich ist es ja wirklich so
dass grundrechte wieder zurückkommen
ich habe das bei meiner oma gemerkt was
bringt es mir wenn sie nicht ins
schwimmbad gehen darf zum beispiel
obwohl sie geimpft ist aber ich finde
ungerecht eigentlich also ich persönlich
finde ich nicht gerecht weil also es
wäre gerecht wenn alle gleichzeitig
kämpfen dürften also ich denke mal dass
jeder genau auf das von der situation
und endlich möchte das wieder zurück zur
normalität geht aber in gewissen neid
verspricht da jetzt nicht also ich hatte
es eigentlich ganz gut mit dieser
rangordnung auch das erst pflegekräfte
und sowas geimpft werden ja da das
entstehen auf jeden fall probleme da
wird es dann so kommen dass der eine
sagt komik in den park spazieren und der
andere muss dann leider daheim bleiben
ich finde es nur richtig es gibt keinen
wirklichen grund mehr weshalb man
grundrechte einschränken sollte bei
menschen die weder gefährdet werden
können oder andere gefährden können
ich kann es verstehen dass junge
menschen sagen wir seien solidarisch
gegenüber den alten und jetzt müssen wir
zurück stecken während die eben
freiheiten zurückbekommen aber
juristisch es trotzdem nicht tragbar
grundrechte weiter einzuschränken
hand aufs herz wie geht es euch spürt
ihr den im kleid oder ist es euch egal
und gleich auch die frage an unseren
psychologen jens lange sind sie neidisch
auf die leute die schon geimpft sind auf
jeden fall erst heute sind in meiner
babbel würde ich jetzt mal so sagen
viele leute damit herausgekommen dass
sie jetzt schon gegeben sind oder
weitergeben werden und ich muss meinen
teil finde ich auf jeden fall night
light gilt als eine der sieben todsünden
ist aber ein uhr menschliches gefühl und
es ist ja sie sagen es selber ist es ja
nachvollziehbar wenn man menschen
bereitet die jetzt einfach besser
geschützt sind gegen das virus oder ja
also mein neid entsteht typischerweise
immer dann wenn man sich mit einer
anderen person vergleicht und diese
person hat irgendeine art von
eigenschaft um dann besitzt du oder eine
leistung die man selbst nicht hat und
das verursacht in einem schmerzhafter
gefühl dafür zieren die unterlegen ist
damit beschäftigt und neid hat dann die
funktion dieses schmerzlichen gefühl
irgendwie zu überwinden und das
natürlich erst mal an sich sehr
hilfreich und sinnvoll
wir haben hier wurden aus youtube
voltaire 236 der schreibt klar bin ich
neidisch aber ich gönne es jedem
einzelnen den senioren im heim den
pflegern die nach der schicht endlich
wieder ohne schlechtes gewissen ein paar
freunde sehen können geht es nach sein
und trotzdem ist in anderen können ja
das geht schon also die grundsätzliche
problematik die nazis diesen schmerz zu
überwinden da durch den vergleich
entsteht in dem fall zum beispiel dass
andere leute schon vorteile genießen
die impfung haben oder so und dann kann
sich neid unterschiedlich auswirken und
zum einen die meisten leute denken wir
daran dass man dann probiert die anderen
zu schädigen indem man zum beispiel
darüber lästerte dass die impfung hat
oder so und das wird gängiger weise als
mist uns gezeigt weil jemand etwas nicht
zu können
aber leute berichten auch noch andere
sachen wenn sie ihn anständig ihre
eigene situation verbessern also zum
beispiel dass es sich mehr anstrengen
herauszufinden man selbst gegeben werden
kann also ich zum beispiel hat mir
gleich heute vorgenommen haben eine
haushalts an zu hoch um zu fragen aber
jedoch über einen trend folge sein
könnte als ich eigentlich selbst immer
dachte also night durchaus auch als
motor
trotzdem ist es eher verpönt dieses
gefühl woher kommt das jaja sich ja
daran wie schon meinte dass die meisten
leute weil man daran denken dass man die
andere person dann entschädigt wenn ich
nur zum beispiel darüber lästern ist bei
solchen die impfung hat bereich bier der
erfolg und die kaputt zu machen so wenn
sie anders als zum beispiel ein
telefonat ab und zu nehmen und runter zu
werfen und das sind das halt so die
klassische vorstand davon dass nadine
sünde ist
aber die leute machen gleich häufig eben
auch andere dinge wie zum beispiel sich
wien zu verbessern aber auch bei der
variante wo man wird die andere person
zu schädigen kann man nicht automatisch
sagen dass das eben was schlechtes ist
lässt dann zum beispiel touren die leute
ja unfassbar gern und das ist auch
gesellschaftlich nicht unbedingt verpönt
und wenn sun zum beispiel dabei hilft in
dieser schmerzlichen situation umzugehen
wie man diese last diesen schmerz von
der seele bekommt ist das ja auch eine
sinnvolle funktion
ok also besser lästern als zu größeren
aggressionen zu greifen
wer ist gibt es menschen die besonders
anfällig für neid sind aber nachdem auf
einem vergleich schnee und anderen
leuten beruht dann sind leute die ja
dazu neigen sich besonders viel zu
vergleichen
ich mach gefährdet da sag ich jetzt mal
19 oder empfinden das eben häufiger und
dadurch ist auch die tipps auch die
eigenschaft häufiger in light
auslösenden situationen zu kommen
zum beispiel wenn man sich häufiger
vergleich oder eben auch leute die sich
selbst für sehr gut halten zum beispiel
personen mit höherem nazismus
wir haben natürlich ganz besondere
probleme wenn andere leute um die ecke
kommen die ihnen etwas überlegen sind
und die ein eigenes haar deswegen auch
dazu dass schmerzhafte gefühle zu und
dann neidisch zu reagieren wenn ihr
fragen an jens lange hat gerne stellen
ich gebe sie dann direkt weiter lange
noch die frage ob junge leute in diesem
fall möglicherweise besonders betroffen
sind von neidgefühlen einfach weil sie
das gefühl haben besonders betroffen von
den maßnahmen zu sein
da besonders eingeschränkt zu sein ja
das kann natürlich sein also der
vergleich zwischen die unter anderen
personen der neid auslöst muss halt
immer in dem bereich seien der entweder
mir und oder den leuten in meinem umfeld
besonders wichtig ist und ich kann mir
jetzt vorstellung war das zu wissen
natürlich junge leute ganz besonders
gerne wie hier rausgehen wollen und
party machen wenn wir sehen können hey
die ganzen älteren leute die gar nicht
mal so viele klubs gehen die können hat
schon wieder oder so dann ist es nicht
unwahrscheinlich dass gerade junge leute
dann besonders neidisch reagieren ist
typisch deutsch also sind wir ein volk
von neidern oder dürfte es im moment
überall ähnlich sein
nein sind kein volk von neidern
zumindest gibt es keine daten wie das
stützen würden
es gibt nur wenige untersuchung die die
neigung zu neid über verschiedene länder
hinweg miteinander vergleichen und die
findet die beweise keine unterschiede
einzige was man sich vorstellen könnte
ist dass man unterschiedliche
dann immer unterschiedliche dinge
neidisch ist seit es eben im kleid eine
sache die vor allem bei deutschen
auftritt aber wir sind nicht generell
neidisch als andere ok als schluss für
diesen ersten part vielleicht noch die
frage wenn das ist ja kein angenehmes
gefühl neid
also schön ist was anderes was kann ich
dagegen tun wenn ich das so tief in
meinem bauch spüren und es nagt
erstmal will ich sagen kann man
entspannt zurück mir und sagen als das
was ganz normal ist ja ich meine dass
ein dieser schmerz darauf hinweist was
einem wichtig ist es ja auch sinnvoll
dass man probiert danach eben was
dagegen zu tun die den schmerz umzugehen
aus der situation herauszukommen und
eben wenn es da zum beispiel dazu führen
würde dass leute eher probieren
herauszufinden wie sie geimpft werden
können ist dass er sogar gesellschaft
was sagen wir mal man vergräbt sich um
ihn so schlechten negativen gefühlen ist
einfach total schlecht drauf
dann könnte man noch andere techniken
anwenden mit dem man emotionen wie
regulieren kann
da erich beispiel so beispielsweise so
was wie sich abzulenken oder die
situation irgendwie umzudeuten dass man
sagen kann herr okay ich kann zwar noch
nicht geben wer nicht ins restaurant
aber vielleicht habe ich da zu hause
noch ein bisschen mehr zeit mama
aufzuräumen und dadurch mein zuhause zu
verschönern
[Gelächter]
entspannt sein ablenken was schönes tun
das sind die tipps von psychologen
erstmal vielen dank wir reden gleich
weiter und holen auch gleich alena books
noch dazu zunächst aber wollen wir in
den bundestag schauen wo die
abgeordneten ja heute den
erleichterungen für die geimpften
zugestimmt haben wenn morgen auch noch
der bundesrat zustimmt treten die
erleichterung am wochenende in kraft
bern benthin hat für uns die diskussion
im parlament beobachtet
mit nachdruck verteidigt die
bundesjustizministerin die neue
rechtsverordnung wo immer freiheit
möglich sei müsse sie auch gewährt
werden
meine damen und herren über was reden
wird denn da wir reden darüber dass in
zukunft menschen dient pflegeheim über
monate hinweg keine kontakte mehr hatten
alleine in ihren zimmern essen mussten
und das schmerzhaft auch gespürt haben
dass die in zukunft wieder ein
speisesaal zusammen essen können für
geimpfte und genesene sollen ausgangs
und kontakt beschränkungen wegfallen
beim einkaufen zum beispiel würden sie
mit getesteten gleichgestellt die masken
pflicht an bestimmten orten soll
weiterhin für alle gelten
die afg stimmt gegen die verordnung und
fordert eine sofortige rücknahme aller
schutzmaßnahmen
mit der vorliegenden verordnung weil sie
kämpften oder genesenen mitmenschen
einen teil ihrer verfassungsmäßig
verbriefte grundrechte wiedergeben
jedoch werden millionen andere weiterhin
diskriminiert
es ist unglaublich was sie hier
vorgetragen haben sprechen sie auch
darüber warum wir dieses grundrecht
einschränken
wir schränken es deshalb ein anderes zur
geltung zu bringen nämlich das recht auf
körperliche unversehrtheit die fdp
enthielt sich bei der abstimmung und
kritisiert die verordnung gingen nicht
weit genug
es ist auch nicht ersichtlich warum der
gastronom der selbst geimpft ist sein
lokal nicht zur genesene und geimpft
öffnen kann
unser grundgesetz schützt in artikel 12
auch die berufsfreiheit
die grünen und die linke stimmen mit der
regierung mahnen aber gleichzeitig mehr
unterstützung für jüngere er noch
ungeimpfte an
gerade eltern junger familien oder
studierende und auszubildende dürfen wir
nicht vergessen sich erwarte von ihnen
endlich investitionen auch des staates
für luftfilter und luftreiniger in
großraumbüros und klassen zu meinen
schon am sonntag soll die verordnung in
kraft treten letzte hürde davor der
bundesrat morgen
der ethikrat berät die bundesregierung
in solchen vor
bei solchen themen die vorsitzende des
ethikrats arena box ist bei uns frau
wuchs im februar noch hat der ethik grad
sich gegen erleichterung für geimpfte
entschieden
jetzt ist ihre haltung aber eine andere
warum verzeihung
wir haben auch schon im februar gesagt
die sich abermals dass geimpfte das
virus nicht mehr weiter tragen können
desto eher müsste man die starken
freiheitseinschränkung zurücknehmen im
februar will ich ganz offen sagen haben
wir nicht erwartet dass dieses szenario
also diese empirische tatsache mit der
nicht infektiosität dass das so schnell
eintreten würde
was ja großartig ist also dass die
impfung noch besser sind als wir das
erwartet haben
dadurch hat sich also die situation
verändert das muss man ganz klar sagen
und entsprechend unterstützen wir auch
dass beispielsweise die quarantäne
pflicht entfällt für menschen die schon
geimpft sind das ja eine sehr sehr
starke freiheitseinschränkung und wir
unterstützen auch oder halten das für
ethisch und problematisch dass man
geimpfte getestete und genesene
gleichstellt also überall wo getestete
bisher sozusagen im geschäft oder im
restaurant wo das möglich ist ein test
vorgewiesen haben
da können geimpfte und genießen das
natürlich auch denn das
robert-koch-institut hat gesagt dass
geimpfte sogar niedrigere risiken haben
noch das virus weiter zu tragen als die
frisch getesteten und wir haben auch
gesagt die masken pflicht ist nichts und
starker eingriff in die persönliche
freiheit nicht so ein starker eingriff
in persönliche grundrechte die kann man
auch noch den geimpften ne weile zumuten
so und damit bleibt ein bereich über der
tatsächlich sehr herausfordernd ist und
das ist der bereich der kontakt
beschränkung und der ausnahmen von der
ganz beschränkung im öffentlichen raum
das ist ebenso ein bereich in dem sehr
sichtbar wird dass eben die eine gruppe
die show geschützt ist
auch noch mehr darf so eine art
doppelten vorteil hat und die andere
gruppe die jetzt zurück gestanden hat
also die die noch nicht geimpft sind
einen doppelten nachteil und das auf den
knackpunkt gestaltet werden genau also
das muss man sich jetzt einfach
politisch angucken das ist eine soziale
spannung und wir müssen einfach
aufpassen dass das nicht eine soziale
spaltung er aber jetzt hat ja die
politik entschieden dass das die die
geimpft sind raus dürfen und zwar immer
das ist ja jetzt sprengkraft dann hätten
sie ist er hätten sie ist der
bundesregierung anders empfohlen
also wir haben es tatsächlich anders
formuliert aber ich höre auch das war
auch bei uns im ethikrat ein ganz
kontroverses thema will ich ganz offen
sagen und die juristischen kollegen
haben immer gesagt wenn wirklich diese
empirische situation eintritt dass
letztlich der sachgrund entfällt der
infektiosität dann wird das einfach
schwierig rechtlich zu halten und dass
das höre ich natürlich aber als
ethikerin habe ich auch immer gesagt das
mag sein aber es ist einfach nicht von
der hand zu weisen dass wir dann eben
eine soziale spannung situation erhalten
die man auch zu recht ungerecht finden
kann und deswegen ist es ganz wichtig
dass das eine kurze übergangsphase ist
also dass wir so schnell und so viel wie
möglich impfen damit möglichst so viele
menschen wie möglich
erstens in diesen genuss kommen zweitens
ist es wichtig dass man eine situation
schafft in der dann die instanzen so
niedrig sind dass möglichst für alle die
beschränkung aufgehoben werden was ja
auch wiederum durch viel impfen
befördert wird also der impfeffekt wird
ja auch die instanzen erniedrigen und
drittens finde ich sollte man da noch
ein bisschen politisch gestalten was
kann man denn jetzt der jungen
generationen das sind ja vor allem die
jungen was kann man denen dennoch
anbieten um das in dieser phase ein
bisschen einfacher zu machen
wir haben sie tipps ja also das eine was
man finde ich machen kann ist es
entfällt ja jetzt für geimpfte und für
genesene in vielen fällen die
entschuldigung die testpflicht da wird
also viel test kapazität frei und da
würde ich sagen das sollte man den
jungen geben dennoch nicht geimpften
also warum nicht zwei oder drei
kostenlose bürger tests die woche warum
nicht auch pcr tests ja noch viel
sicherer sind gerade bevorzugt dann
jetzt für die nicht geimpften wenn es um
so fragen geht für eine familie die doch
irgendwo hin bereits muss eltern sind
schon geimpft kinder geht noch nicht da
geht ja diese spannung sozusagen durch
die familie durch da angebote zu machen
und natürlich brauchen wir insgesamt
sowieso ganz viel unterstützung für die
junge generation die echt ziemlich
gebeutelt wurde durch diese pandemie
ihre worte werden gut ankommen ich habe
noch ganz kurz wir kommen da auch gleich
noch mal zurück herr lange sehr lange
muss ich mich gleich verabschieden weil
er seinen sohn noch hüten muss eine
letzte frage wie wie spalterisch kann
neid für eine gesellschaft werden wie
sehen sie das
wie sehr muss man da aufpassen ich
glaube nicht dass nein nein jetzt die
gesellschaftliche spaltung vorantreiben
wird das wäre mainz so einfach ich meine
viele leute schreiben ein ganz
verrückter eigenschaften geschätzt
aber jetzt zu sagen weil man sich mit
anderen leuten und sich den vergleich
dass man rausgeht und nicht hängen sie
protestieren oder rechte einzufordern
oder zu anderen ich glaube das kann
nicht nur offenheit zurückgehen wenn
dann wären ein beitrag dazu
zusammen mit all den anderen diese zeit
jetzt auch die leute hatte danke in für
ihr schlusswort ich wünsche ihnen jetzt
viel spaß mit ihrem sohn und danke dass
sie aus dieser familienzeit sich zeit
für uns genommen haben
dankeschön jens lange und frau büchs wir
reden gleich weiter schauen uns noch mal
an das neidgefühle ja mitunter erst dann
richtig zum tragen kommen wenn man sieht
dass andere ihr glück der impfung
intensiv teilen jan fischer über freude
und fakten zum thema impfung
endlich sicherheit endlich gegen das
virus geschützt
bei vielen ist die freude derzeit riesig
leute impfen fest ich habe heute meinen
zweiten kicks bekommen und bin so
glücklich wie seit über einem jahr nicht
mehr
gestern war es endlich soweit ein erster
schritt in richtung normalität
genau diesen schritt können immer mehr
menschen gehen denn im vergleich zum
schleppenden im staat wurde in
deutschland zuletzt der im turbo
eingelegt allein gestern wurden über
eine million impfdosen verabreicht
insgesamt haben nunmehr als 25,4
millionen menschen ihre erste spritze
bekommen
das entspricht 30,6 prozent der
bevölkerung mehr als 7,1 millionen
menschen sind vollständig geimpft 8,6
prozent es sind zahlen die auch neid
erzeugen vor allem dann wenn gefährdete
menschen kein termin bekommen die stiko
mahnt jetzt an der priorisierung müsse
festgehalten werden
es gebe noch zu viele impf bereite mit
einem erhöhten risiko etwa jüngere mit
vorerkrankung von ihnen waren zuletzt
noch drei viertel ohne ersten punkt
roddicks ich habe hier einen kommentar
von brusio dg aus youtube
er sagt am anfang oder sie hieß es man
könne keinen lockdown nur für die
risikogruppen aus gründen der
solidarität machen
jetzt sind diese risikogruppen geimpft
und dürfen raus während alle anderen in
quarantäne bleiben müssen jetzt spricht
keiner mehr über solidarität können sie
den frust nachvollziehen
ja also ich find das mal ganz wichtig
das ist einer der gründe weshalb ich
heute abend gekommen bin das man
unterstreicht dass es hier wenn
überhaupt nur ein bisschen um neid geht
ich finde dass so ein bisschen ungnädig
diese ganze diskussion abzutun als so
eine art light reflex der jungen auf die
schon geimpften das ist viel viel
komplexer natürlich gibt's das hat er
lange ja auch gerade schon gesagt
natürlich gibt es leute die neidgefühle
haben aber die können gleichzeitig das
anderen gönnen
und ich glaube es ist sogar eher etwas
was eine untergeordnete rolle spielt
viel wichtiger sind eben erhebliche
überlegung und dazu gehören überlegungen
die sich mit gerechtigkeit und
solidarität beschäftigen die sind
einfach viel berechtigter als sozusagen
so eine negative emotionen deswegen
finde ich das ganz wichtig zu sagen dass
es eben aus meiner sicht keine
neiddebatte ist die sau die uns zu
dieser lockt jetzt so der doktor frage
ganz ehrlich beantwortet hat also
initial ging's wurde vor allem gesagt
was sie dass man so ein lockdown für
diese wilde rahmen also diese
risikogruppen den karts konnte man und
das sagen die fachleute nach wie vor
einfach praktisch nicht machen weil es
eine viel zu große gruppe ist die zu
teilen mitten in der gesellschaft ja
auch lebt das sind ja jetzt nicht nur in
die leute die man quasi hinter
glasscheiben stecken könnte das war ein
ganz wesentlicher grund und wenn man
dann gesagt wir machen das und man hätte
aber nicht richtig gemacht dann hätte
das zu ganz ganz viel todesfällen
geführt
aber der punkt mit der solidarität die
kann ich nicht verstehen ich formuliere
das noch mal anders
wir sind als gesellschaft ja alle zurück
gestanden für die priorisierten gruppen
die zuerst geimpft wurden das haben wir
alle gerne gemacht das hat noch hohe
unterstützung
bevölkerung gehabt über 90 prozent haben
gesagt die priorisierung ist richtig das
ist gut
und dann kann ich das verstehen dass man
sagt wir waren nicht solidarisch
jetzt ist es schwierig für uns dass wir
zu gucken müssen dass er diesen
doppelten nachteil haben wir haben für
euch zurück gestand wir hätten
eigentlich auch grundrechtlichen
anspruch gehabt auf den
gesundheitsschutz durch die impfung aber
gesagt den stemmer zurück ihr habt es
bekommen und jetzt kriegt ihr nicht nur
den schutz
das haben wir alles super gern gemacht
sondern er kriegt auch noch diese
freiheitsgrade zurück und wie gesagt die
meisten leute können das aber es ist
berechtigt zu sagen kann 'die
gesellschaft' irgend etwas für uns tun
um das jetzt abzumildern denn das dauert
für viele jüngere halt doch auch noch
eine ganze weile also ich kann das
nachvollziehen mir hier kommt von louis
vierne von youtube meiner meinung nach
dürften diese erleichterungen
fairerweise erst in kraft treten wenn
die impf priorisierung aufgehoben ist
und sich jeder bei wunsch impfen lassen
kann
ja das ist dass es eben einer dieser
argumentation zu sagen solange man
eigentlich erwähnt man will sich ja
empfinde aber man kann doch nicht ist
das liegt das halt tatsächlich besonders
schwer
ich glaube wir werden sehr schnell voran
kommen jetzt mit dem impfen
also es gibt ja so schätzung das anfang
juli alle aus den risikogruppen wirklich
ihr angebot bekommen haben und man dann
die priorisierung auslaufen lassen kann
und dass wir sehr sehr schnell die
breite kommen werden also es wird davon
gesprochen die betriebsärzte kommen noch
dazu dass die tempo wird nochmal
deutlich anziehen also man kann schon
viel hoffnung machen dass das jetzt eine
kurze phase ist aber noch mal ich finde
das sollte anerkannt werden dass das
nicht irgendein billiger neid ist
sondern dass das nachvollziehbar ist
dass man das eben tatsächlich schwierig
findet und rechtlich scheint es einfach
sehr klar zu sein dass man diese
einschränkung weil den kontakten und bei
der ausgangs beschränkungen nicht
durchziehen kann
für die geimpften und genesen sind aber
dann wünsche ich mir tatsächlich auch
mehr
gebote für diejenigen die jetzt noch
eine ganze weile zurückstehen müssen sie
haben vorhin schon gesagt die angebote
mehr tests für jugendliche und junge
leute gibt es noch was was sie unter
mehr angeboten subsumieren
oder ist vielleicht auch einfach
zuspruch gehört werden
das ist überhaupt nicht trivial also ich
wollte doch zwei dinge sagen dass eines
ich finde es ist schon auch wichtig dass
die politik das ernst nimmt und das
einfach auch thematisiert und das
anerkennen dass das sozusagen noch eine
weitere solidarische leistung ist das
ist nicht nichts wenn das wertgeschätzt
wird das ist das eine und das andere ist
das ist auch ein bisschen botschaft an
uns alle letztlich und vor allem auch an
die geimpften ich wünsche mir da eine
gewisse rücksicht ich will meine
anekdote erzählen von einer freundin die
mir das gesagt hat die saas neulich im
zug in einem völlig lern abteil
ungeimpft setzt sich jemand direkt
nehmen sie maske auf halb acht
und sie freut fragt ihn ganz freundlich
ob er vielleicht ein stückchen weiter in
den waggon eingehen könnte der komplett
leer war und er bläst sie an und sagte
ich bin doppelt geimpft
ich bin nicht aussetzen und das ist so
die art von verhalten die einfach
schwieriges erstes in mich geglaubt hat
sich dann selber weg gesetzt weil sie
dachte schwierig und ich meine ich sitzt
will nicht neben dem sitzen jetzt ist
für mich noch ein risiko ich habe den
schutz noch nicht aber zweitens kommt da
ebenso eine haltung zu tage die nicht
besonders wertschätzend ist und ich
glaube es die uns auch überhaupt nicht
ich habe
diejenigen die jetzt schon geimpft sind
die wir dann würde ich wirklich daran
appellieren dass man das einfach
rücksichtsvoll macht wird es nicht so
rein reibt sozusagen sie haben vorhin
auch die eltern angesprochen eltern und
kinder sind ja auch so eine so eine
gruppe die echt viel zu leisten und
tragen haben im moment selbst da noch
von von ihrer seite einen vorschlag wie
man denen so entgegenkommen kann es gab
ja auch mal die forderungen eltern
müssten in der prioritätenliste weiter
hoch kommen in den impfpass prioritäten
haben sie dann die idee den vorschlag
also ich würde jetzt wenn diese jetzige
priorisierung ausläuft würde ich nicht
noch mal eine komplette neue
priorisierung machen es war nie die idee
dass man die ganze bevölkerung quasi
soll ja da kommt küche aber dass man pro
aktiv und sozusagen gezielt durchaus
gerade familien unterstützt find ich
persönlich eigentlich eine gute idee da
ich weiß im übrigen dass das jetzt schon
zum teil auch niedergelassene ärztinnen
und ärzte machen die haben eine gewisse
flexibilität dass die auch schon unter
ihren risikopatienten gucken werten da
kleine kinder und das kann man
weitermachen dass man einfach sagt schau
die betriebsärzte guckt auf die jungen
leute guckt einfach auf die die
ansonsten noch ewig warten müssen am
schwierigsten wird es für die
jugendlichen und die kinder da gibt es
ja gar keine impfung
und nochmal da brauchen wir eine reihe
von maßnahmen tests also auch in den
schulen kann man das testen noch
intensivieren aber wir brauchen da eben
auch unterstützungsprogramme
kompensations programme kreative ideen
wie man diese bildungs verluste und die
belastungen die in der ganz jungen
generation erfolgt sind wie man die
einfach sozusagen ein bisschen
ausgleichen und ein bisschen mildern
kann
der kreative ideen sind auf jeden fall
gefragt ich kommen noch mal hier auf
ronny knüpfer über facebook fragt er ja
nie gibt er ihnen recht warum wird über
neid und nicht über gerechtigkeit
gesprochen night impliziert bereits eine
negative haltung das hatten sie gesagt
über youtube kommt der wahre kollege
frau box inwiefern wäre es vertretbar
alle beschränkungen wieder aufzuheben
sobald alle ein impfangebot erhalten
haben
egal ob sie es annehmen oder nicht ist
eine sehr gute und und wirklich
schwierige frage denn tatsächlich ist es
jetzt mal in der ersten ethische
betrachtung so wenn das ganze eine
private entscheidung ist dann ist ja die
impfung ist das mildere mittel als jetzt
lockt das und solche sachen das ist
völlig klar
die ist sehr effektiv und wenn jeder
sich jederzeit auch umsonst noch also es
gibt keine höhlen keine finanziellen
hören es gibt keine
praktische hürden das ist total
niedrigschwellig überall verfügbar wenn
jeder sich impfen lassen kann dann
erlischt eigentlich die
schutzverpflichtung durch den staat ein
stärkeres mittel einzusetzen als hilfen
anzubieten muss man einfach so sagen und
ich gehe eigentlich auch davon aus dass
wenn sich wirklich alle ganz entspannt
impfen lassen können dass wir dann
sowieso in der situation sind wo das wo
das einfach sozusagen letztlich das
überwinden der pandemie bedeutet dann
werden die inzidenz zahlt total
kollabieren
wir haben insgesamt in deutschland eine
immer weiter wachsende impfbereitschaft
also ich bin da sehr sehr zuversichtlich
jetzt hammer noch die kinder und die
jugendlichen und die eine sorge ist dass
da sozusagen das virus quasi dann ganz
stark zirkuliert und kinder und
jugendliche haben zwar niedrige risiken
aber sie haben schon risiken es gibt
schon schwere fälle es gibt auch loco
wird und solche sachen
das heißt die verpflichtung zum beispiel
die schulen pandemie sicher zu machen
erlischt überhaupt nicht und mit blick
auf virus mutter mutation und solche
dinge würde ich sagen dass man eine
reihe von maßnahmen auch dann noch
rechtfertigen kann wenn alle sich ganz
entspannt impfen können und das sind so
basismaßnahmen die einfach nicht so
starke eingriffe in die grundrechte
bedeuten also die maske abstandsgebot
und solche dinge aber das wird man sich
anschauen müssen
wie sich dann so das ganze pandemie
geschehen verändert es ist hier so es
kommt viel so von wegen ich staune nur
wer schon alles geimpft ist
wer sich vordrängeln darf jetzt party
machen und wer brav auf seinen termin
wartet muss zu hause bleiben da ist
unmut da aber auch die fragen
ich bin noch nicht geimpft aber ich bin
für die rückgabe der freiheiten es gäbe
übrigens 0 neid wenn die getesteten
dieselben frei hätten hätten wie die
geimpften da spricht hier aber auch
einiges dagegen also zwei dinge zu
diesem ersten punkt das ist die art von
und die ich meine das ist kein neid
sondern das ist auch ein ärger darüber
dass da einfach natürlich beim impfen
weiß gott nicht alles super gelaufen ist
und dass man jetzt sozusagen ich dachte
das mal so sagen das haben wir nämlich
freunde quasi wortwörtlich gestern beim
telefonieren noch gesagt so zu sagen wer
sich brav einfach darauf verlässt dass
wieder alles gut laufen stellt auf
einmal fest oder ich muss hier sozusagen
einchecken
ja ich muss mich jetzt voll reinhängen
und und sonst ziehen ganz viel an mir
vorbei und das wissen um bahn das kann
ich verstehen man will eigentlich braver
bürger sein und sich sozusagen an die
regeln halten und dann sollte das schon
passen und das ist noch noch es dafür
dass impft tempo sozusagen zu niedrig
als dass jetzt schon absehbar wäre dass
man mit der haltung sehr bald impftermin
kriegt das ist ein echtes problem
deswegen hoffe ich darauf dass es im
land wirklich wirklich hoch geht und
dann immer mehr stellen gm fährt damit
diese diese erfahrung einfach
verschwindet und alle wissen das passt
schon wir kommen alle zu unserer impfung
und das wird bald so sein hoffe ich ja
ich höre was eine zweite punkt ja
entschuldigung wir waren ein zweiter
punkt
naja warum getestete nicht gleich mit
geimpft werden können
also werden sie jetzt in vielerlei
hinsicht also überall dort wo man
sozusagen mit dem test quasi als
eintritt operiert hatte und sobald man
unter die bundes notbremsen grenze kommt
wird das ja auch an vielen stellen
wieder sein also in beim friseur
restaurant zum teil oder oder beim
geschäft oder sonst irgendwas da wird es
diese gleichstellung geben und es wird
im moment intensiv diskutiert ob man
nicht noch mehr machen sollte und
sozusagen diese ausnahmen von der
kontakt beschränkung und die ausnahmen
von der ausgangs beschränkung auch für
frisch getestete einführen sollte da
kann ich nur wiederholen was mir die
kolleginnen und kollegen sagen die da
einschlägiger sind aus den jeweiligen
wissenschaftlichen feldern das risiko
von nicht geimpften und genesen sind das
virus weiter zu tragen ist einfach doch
noch deutlich niedriger als bei frisch
getesteten weil das das getestete ist ja
kein schutz
das ist nur dass das zeigt eine jetzt
bist du gerade nicht
ansteckend und die anti gen test
erwischen auch nicht alles leider
deswegen plädiere ich dafür sehr viel
mehr auch wieder die pcr test in den
vordergrund zu rücken denn die sind viel
sicherer
und da hat man dann schon fenster sah
man zehn oder zwölf stunden fensters
wird ja schon helfen bei dem man sagen
könnte also dann könnte man tatsächlich
über noch eine weitergehende
gleichstellung nachdenken dass sich
jetzt so gedanken
sollte sich die politik machen und das
eben alles für die nächsten wochen
hoffentlich nur noch maximal 12 monate
besser zu gestalten für diejenigen die
noch nicht geimpft sind zehn stunden
fenster klingt ja schon großartig und
ein bis zwei monate noch durchhalten
müssen uns halt alle immer wieder sagen
ich danke ihnen sehr herzlich für das
gespräch und die ihnen die informationen
wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen abend
und danke euch ganz herzlich für die in
die anregungen und fragen die kamen und
sack für heute schluss und wünschen noch
einen schönen abend
[Musik]